Water and Power have returned to key for
day after Russian strikes caused
widespread outages the city's mayor said
residents should still expect planned
power Cuts due to damages from Russian
attacks the temporary cut left hundreds
lining up for water in the Ukrainian
Capital the attacks are part of moscow's
strategy to Target key civilian
facilities as the winter nears around a
third of Ukraine's power stations have
now been destroyed
is in Kiev for us this morning so the
water and power supplies have been
restored what do you reckon how long can
that last
that's a good question but mostly most
likely uh if there are uh new attacks of
course we will see what they bring but
if there are no new attacks for the
moment everything is working again of
course there are still shortages so
there will still be power Cuts that's
officially confirmed that they will
continue the scheme of cutting of the
power in certain areas of the city for
some time uh uh some some hours a day
basically that's in order to minimize
pressure on the electricity grid because
power supply there is a shortage of
power but every household that's what
the officials are saying is now
reconnected to power and to water and
yeah there are no new distractions to
some extent this will this will continue
working
now the international atomic energy
agency has begun new inspections to
Ukraine what's the background for that
Russia has accused the Ukraine of
preparing a dirty bomb that is a bomb
that contains radioactive energy
although it's not a nuclear bomb that
sets off uh the process uh the in the
nuclear the the nuclear um
process explosion process
um but that will
spread the radioactivity around and
the eiaa is expecting
um the two places that Russia are
accusing Ukraine of uh of preparing them
they have been there before these the
photos that Russia has posted as
evidence have been
verified they are false they are fake
but still the iaea is coming to inspect
these two places where they have been
before in order to make sure and to
probably debunk these Russian
accusations
reporting from Keith thank you Matthias
and Matthias building also filed our
next report it's not only Russians and
ukrainians fighting against each other
in Ukraine you can also find many ethnic
chechins on both sides of the war
chechnya's ruler ramzan khadirov has
sent soldiers to help the Russians and
yet Ukraine has a battalion named after
a Chechen independence leader full of
men Keen to fight against the Russians
thank you
storming a building
this is a training session for new
recruits to Ukraine's Joker dudai of
Battalion the Chechen volunteer group
fighting for Ukraine
they are from the very first to go into
newly won territory
our job is to storm and to clear the
place
after that the other groups come in and
do their job
as he calls himself was born in chechnya
but grew up in Europe he says he's
always dreamed of fighting against
Russia
after Putin the next Crimea and
installed proxies in the donbass Maga
moved to Ukraine he joined the Battalion
which Bears the colors of Chechen
Independence and the name of its hero
johannev
foreign this has been going on for
Generations my father fought against
Russia and the first and second Chechen
wars in the 1990s and I must continue
this fight
[Applause]
the Battalion was among the first to
enter the town of izum
as the Chechen volunteers fight for
Ukraine many consider it part of their
greater battle against Russia
we want to go home we want to liberate
our country
after Ukraine we will go home
these are anti-russian chechens but
there are also chechins fighting on the
other side militias sent by ramzan
kajirov the Putin loyalists who rules
chechnya with an iron fist
the to dive Battalion is proud of its
roots but new recruits don't have to be
Chechen ukrainians can join too
they don't get official training or
payment the Battalion relies on
donations and their own enthusiasm
which is a
joke you can try to learn a lot about
war
but what counts is to make practical use
of it
when the moment of combat comes some
people falter psychologically or
otherwise that's why the most important
thing is to have strong motivation a
strong idea
in idea
the group is away from the front now
waiting for new instructions preparing
to return
chechens and ukrainians fighting a
common cause
ships full of grain have been leaving
Ukrainian ports despite Russia's pulling
out of an agreement that allowed them
safe passage the deal was broken by
turkey and the United Nations and from
its ships to bypass Russia's blockade of
the Ukrainian Coast
now these ships cross the Black Sea to
Turkey before heading to various
International destinations so far more
than 9.5 million tons of corn wheat and
other grains have made it out but this
is far less than Ukraine exported before
the war
Spain has received the most grain so far
according to figures from the United
Nation turkey comes next followed by
China and Italy out of the nine and a
half million tons in total the UN world
food program has sent 60 000 tons to
Yemen and Ethiopia countries with high
levels of food insecurity the deal was
said to expire later this month and now
Russia has warned that it will be
dangerous to try to enforce the
agreement now that it has pulled out
let's get more on this from DW Russia
analyst concert in Eggert who joins us
from uh Vilnius this morning uh
constantly dangerous what could this
mean
well so far again it means just that the
Kremlin wants to issue yet another
threat but doesn't know whether it will
follow with some kind of concrete action
um I think that uh for Putin today the
kind of the the the scale or the set of
tools that he can use to pressure
International Community is very limited
and after the attack on the Russian
Black Sea Fleet base in the occupied
Crimea he decided to go for the old Tire
tactic of
um you know threatening hunger to the
world but I think that this threat today
to me doesn't sound very incredible now
Ukraine intends to continue exporting
grain via the Black Sea despite all this
now can we anticipate how long Russia
will suspend this agreement
I don't think Russia suspended this
agreement because so far I mean the
sheeps are sailing uh I think that this
is an attempt to pressure for example
turkey again into coming in and trying
to negotiate something showing that
Russia is not alone that Russia has
listened to but frankly imagine Russian
ships now blocking a Ukrainian freighter
with with grain these days as opposed to
spring it will look really really bad
especially actually for the countries
and they'll say in Africa or in Asia
which get quite a bit of this grain and
these countries now actually form at
least some part of international support
for culture uh and I don't think that
Putin would like this picture to be
beamed
um
kind of via TV screens across the world
so I think it's just a threat but so far
no more than that no more than words
and our constantly we've we've heard
that Russia had changed its tax tactics
because of setbacks uh on on the on the
battlefields uh is that why there are
now these massive attacks on civilian
infrastructure
I think that uh the Kremlin and its
commanders believe that
um if they actually relentlessly destroy
Ukrainian infrastructure the population
will be tired and will pressure
president zielinski to start peace
negotiations so uh I think that in
absence of any kind of meaningful
military successes the only way for
putting is to actually continue to
Pummel a civilian infrastructure kill
civilians so essentially it's a terror
war against Ukraine
thank you very much DW's Russia analyst
Constantine eggerte